we all scream
yes queen
for pride month the venetian resort is
tasting the rainbow with a special
cocktail at the electric cocktail club
and lead bartender daniel young is here
to give us a sip
a sassy set yes ma'am i'm ready i'm
ready okay so before we get to sipping
though how does the venetian honor the
pride community and pride month in
general so in recognition of the lgbtqia
community we are honoring pride month
with a series of treats across the
venues so we'll have special cakes
special shakes and special cocktails at
some of our partner venues as well okay
and it's called the cocktail collective
right yes okay so what bars are part of
that collective so we have the dorsey
which was the first one we opened and
then electra and rosina okay so before
we start talking about the electra drink
let's talk about the other ones at the
other bars because we have them here as
well yes we do okay let's talk so at
rosina you'll have show your true colors
it's going to be i love that fix
variation with fresh lemon fresh house
made simple syrup a little bit of uh gin
and strawberries in there as well look
at that
nice and refreshing and there's a
rainbow colored sugar rim on that as
well was there was there a
could you guys see that
sorry it's been sitting this it's melted
a little bit
okay and the sprinkles are so good oh
yeah wow okay moving on secondly at
dorsey we have what is called
this is love is love
it's a variation of a traditional sour
so it's going to have egg whites it's
going to have fresh muddled strawberries
shaken inside as well as a little bit of
blanc vermouth to accompany the vodka
that way it's a little easier to drink
and can have four or five of them
without really getting knocked out see
that
exactly that egg white concept for a
drink i
what is it is it what causes the froth
yes yes so it gives it more body it
helps kind of suspend the ingredients so
it's more smooth going down a little
velvety on the beginning okay okay well
it is time
it is time yes give me your best yes
queen yes queen
did you feel that okay let's talk about
electra's so it's a variation of a
queen's park swizzle with more emphasis
on the queen so of course it's going to
have fresh mint it's going to have fresh
lime juice okay we're going to use our
own house made or shot which is an
almond syrup that we get from you know
just basically extracting all the almond
flavors and adding sugar to it beautiful
okay it's going to have a lot of great
flavors in there all right beautiful
and okay so what how is this going to
taste going down is it is it tangy is it
sweet it's a combination we like to
focus on balance okay so we're not going
to emphasize too many
that was a bar yeah
we wanted to have a little touch of
bitterness so we have april in there to
kind of change it up a little okay and
all that's going to kind of lean into
the other profiles that we have going in
perfect so let's get shaking all right
well unfortunately we don't have that we
have kind of a time constraint so i made
the cocktail ahead of time okay what are
we going to do just finished we love a
prepared queen yeah we love a prepared
queen all right so crushed ice very key
here give it a nice pour
so what's the energy like at the
electric cocktail club so elektra is
kind of a focus on energy we're a faux
tiki nightclub bar that offers a wide
variety of you know rums and moscow's
that's where we focus on okay but we do
offer cocktails as well as you know the
occasional vodka soda if you need it
right something for everybody right
that's what pride month is all about
and then
overall i think you guys have other you
mentioned cakes and shakes what are some
of the other spots in the venetian that
are having specials that we can take
advantage of this month thank you for
asking we do offer the crazy shake uh
the fried crazy shake at black tap which
oh i love that burgers and amazing
milkshake which
if you want you can make them alcoholic
which is awesome
and then on top of that we also have
carlos bakery and bouchon offering
rainbow cakes so this is how beautiful
we saw a picture of that earlier as well
as we offer pride themed apparel
throughout the venues as well oh cool
okay so a little bit everything for
everyone
the fresh mint smells so good i'll let
you go ahead
oh slippery so it's okay it's okay there
you go oh the finishing touch a little
rainbow flag yeah all right so this is
how it comes served up at electra
cocktail club
drink up oh please okay
here we go
jazz queen right
yes queen that is good oh my gosh the
flavors are so good okay of course head
down to the venetian yes and enjoy all
of these sweet and tangy sassy treats
and come see me i'll be there oh okay
perfect you don't need more incentive
than that thank you daniel
we'll be right back